one of the peak reality show moments of last
night's state of the union address by Donald
Trump, a running 78 minutes and being riddled
with lies and distortion and reality show
moments.
Uh, one of the things that, um, was absent
was policy and Donald Trump instead did cheap
stunts like surprising extremist right-wing
radio host rush Limbaugh with the presidential
medal of freedom.
Check out that moment.
Rush in the news lately because he announced
that he has been diagnosed with advanced lung
cancer.
He was there as Trump's guest.
And here is Trump surprising him with the
presidential medal of freedom.
I am proud to announce tonight that you will
be receiving our country's highest civilian,
the presidential
medal of freedom.
Shortly after this, Melania Trump put the
metal on rush.
So, so I want to be really clear here.
I'm not happy.
Rush Limbaugh has lung cancer.
We're going to hear a voicemail later today
from a caller about this.
I find rush Limbaugh's politics, disgusting
and destructive, but I would not wish cancer
on anyone I know personally.
The nightmare of having a loved one diagnosed
with cancer and serious illness.
I have nothing to say that would even hint
at pleasure at rush Limbaugh having cancer.
Separate from that, rush Limbaugh is a disgusting,
horrible extremist who should not have the
medal of freedom.
It devalues the honor of the medal of freedom
to give it to rush Limbaugh.
This is the rush Limbaugh who called Barack
Obama the magic Negro in a song parody.
This is bullshit as Al Sharpton about Barrack
Obama, the matching name and [inaudible] Kong
and that causes not [inaudible].
This is a guy who mocked Michael J. Fox is
Parkinson's by pretending to shake uncontrollably
and claimed that uh, Michael J. Fox is playing
up the Parkinson's
in this commercial.
He is exaggerating the effects of the disease.
He is moving all around and shaking and it's
purely an act.
This is the only time I have ever seen Michael
J. Fox for Trey, any of the symptoms of the
disease he had.
He can control himself enough to stay in the
frame of the picture and he can control himself
enough to keep his eyes right on the lens.
The teleprompter,
that guy is the one that Donald Trump surprised
with the presidential medal of freedom last
night.
But you know, my, my girlfriend's grandmother
was awarded the presidential medal of freedom
by president Clinton for a life's work, cleaning
up children's television, developing educational
programming, keeping advertisers that are
predatory to kids out of kids' TV, working
with the house and Senate, improving people's
lives.
And then rush Limbaugh gets it after Barack
the magic Negro and making fun of Parkinson's.
It's a guy rush Limbaugh with a career of
sexist, racist, xenophobic comments.
Famously calling healthcare advocate Sandra
fluke, a slut that was an entire other national
fiasco.
So the metal ends up meaning less instantly
when Donald Trump gives it to rush Limbaugh
in this cartoonish reality show stunt men
merely to get attention.
It's classless to use a national address to
give a reactionary talk show host a metal
for nothing more than being a Trump Trump
supporter.
Because that's really what this is about.
Limbo is sick now.
He supports Trump and here's a way to do something
that will get attention.
Imagine for a second, like it's hard to even
come up with an example like bill Maher or
I don't, John Stewart, I don't even know.
Imagine that Barack Obama was impeached by
a Republican house and hours from being acquitted
by a democratic Senate in a total sham trial
and the day before during a state of the union,
Barack Obama says, surprise bill Maher or
surprise John Stewart.
Here's the presidential medal of freedom.
The right would go nuts.
They would be apoplectic.
And you know, bill Maher and jr John Stewart
aren't even good examples because they were
critical of Barack Obama.
There almost is not a good example.
We're living in a society where logic, reason
and thought have been replaced by ignorance,
pandering and almost a proud, uh, um, uh,
a proud defiance about falling for one thing
to fall for wanting to be sucked into these
meaningless stunts.
The reality show nature of what's going on
and we're in trouble.
I mean, we're, we're just in serious trouble
as a result.
Let me know what you thought about the state
of the union address.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
Follow me there